la vérité c'est que vous êtes paralysé
par la peur vous avez peur de finir
comme Monsieur Castaner limoger en 48
heures pour avoir dénoncé les clés
d'étranglement le syndicat de police
Allianz qui représente plus de 50 % aux
dernières élections tiens le
gouvernement que le gouvernement ne veut
pas s'affronter au syndicat de police
Alliance quand cesserez-vous d'être
pétrifié et comprendrez-vous enfin les
mesures fortes pour recréer et réparer
et recréer les liens que vous avez
laissés se désagréger dans les pays
connus pour leur passé colonial le
racisme culturel s'est transformé en
racisme institutionnel l'architecture
sociale construite par cette mentalité
est à l'origine des événements qui ont
commencé en France et ce sont étendus à
d'autres pays en peu de temps je
voudrais vous poser la question que se
pose tous les Français qu'avez-vous fait
de la France vous qui menez la même
politique que vos prédécesseurs depuis
40 ans
qu'avez-vous fait de notre pays en y
implantant des zones d'un endroit que
vous avez laissé ce communautariser ce
criminaliser confirme que l'un des
policiers a bien dit je vais te mettre
une balle dans la tête que l'autre a
bien dit shoot le que des coups de cross
3 ont été donnés à Naëlle parler d'eux
policiers je me désolidarise totalement
des propos de Jean-Luc Mélenchon de
certains de ses députés qui ont refusé
d'appeler au calme et qui ont légitimé
cette violence en disant c'est normal
c'est une révolte non
c'est pour ça que je me désolidarise
totalement le chaos sécuritaire qui a
touché l'ensemble notre pays s'inscrit
bien sûr dans le cas aux migratoires que
nous subissons et contre lequel vous
restez les bras ballants malgré nos
alertes depuis des années le
gouvernement continue la politique de
l'autruche il faut désormais suspendre
les allocations familiales et les
allocations sociales aux parents de
mineurs récidivistes car il serait
absolument inadmissible que les Français
qui bossent que les Français qui se
lèvent tôt soit contraint de payer les
dégâts qu'ils n'ont pas commis moins de
les d'un dossiers qu'on n'a pas etc
pourquoi parce qu'elle vous a pas là
pour ça
je suis encore assez grand pour savoir
pourquoi
c'est moi c'est moi qui c'est moi qui
dirige ici les démarches nous sommes
nombreux ici Monsieur le Député être
issu des quartiers à être issus
d'immigration et à aimer notre pays et
nous ne voulons ni de la haine des
policiers ni de la haine des étrangers
l'exécutif au chevet également des
maires de banlieue aujourd'hui façon
grand débat national cette fois sous les
dorures de l'Elysée le président promet
des réponses à ses élus sur le qui-vive
depuis une semaine êtes-vous oui ou non
favorable à l'abrogation du permis de
tuer de la loi Cazeneuve qui a provoqué
l'explosion du nombre de morts en cas de
refus d'obtempérer allez-vous oui ou non
créer un comité vérité et justice pour
faire toute la transparence sur les cas
de violences policières ah je demande
pas de rustine on se débrouillera on va
penser les plaies comme d'habitude je
demande qu'on est parce qu'on est à le
refaire dans cinq ans et ça c'est pas
uniquement quelques subventions pour
remplacer des caméras qui nous
permettront d'en sortir
quand j'ai et nous traite de chien de
garde vous sortez du champ républicain
j'attends qu'il s'occupe de la France et
des Français parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'il laisse en déshérence le pays
préférant aller à un concert Delton John
plutôt que de s'occuper de la sécurité
lorsque le pays brûle criminel imbécile
s'en sont pris y compris à des écoles
primaires à des écoles maternelles donc
évidemment l'objectif pour nous c'est
d'accueillir immédiatement les enfants
de réconforter les parents qui étaient
en pleurs un journaliste du Parisien
rapporte cet échange
[Musique]
mais les gamins ils écoutent qui alors
les dealers monsieur le Président c'est
d'ailleurs eux qui commencent à leur
demander de se calmer et depuis deux
jours parce que tout ce bazar c'est en
train de donner du tort à leur business
monsieur le député
faites mentir la
frappe pas en effet des révolutionnaires
vous êtes des petits révoltés soyez au
rendez-vous de la République